السياسيون والأمير وغيرهم من
الرجال البارزين هوياتهم كلها موجودة في
وثائق جيفري إبستين الجديدة التي تم الكشف عنها
يوم الأربعاء، إنها الدفعة الأولى من
ملفات المحكمة المختومة المتعلقة بالمتاجر بالجنس الراحل والتي تم
إصدارها بعد
أمر القاضي الشهر الماضي مع عشرات
الوثائق الأخرى التي سيتم نشرها قريبًا
لدائرة إبستين  من Associates
معروف جيدًا ولكن السجلات توفر للجمهور
المزيد من السياق حول العالم الحصري
الذي سافر إليه أثناء مواجهته اتهامات
بسوء السلوك. أود أن أقول إنه
ليس هناك الكثير من الجديد في هذا ولكني
أعتقد أنه من المهم أن يتمكن
الجمهور من الوصول إلى  الوثائق
لأنها لا تتعلق فقط بإبستين،
فالصفحات تذكر شخصيات بارزة بما في ذلك
الأمير أندرو الرئيس السابق بيل
كلينتون ودونالد ترامب، وتنبع من
دعوى تشهير مدنية تم رفعها في عام 2015
ضد صديقة إبستين السابقة
جالين ماكسويل،
بما في ذلك إفادات تم التقاطها في عام 2016 من جوانا.
قالت شيرج التي عملت لدى إبستين
في الوثيقة إنها أجرت
محادثة مع إبستين واقتبست أنه قال ذات
مرة إن كلينتون تحبهم صغارًا في
إشارة إلى الفتيات عندما سئلت عما إذا
كانت كلينتون صديقة لإبستين، قالت إنها
تفهم أن إبستين كان يتعامل
مع كلينتون  لم يتم
اتهام كلينتون بأي جرائم أو مخالفات
تتعلق بإبستاين، ونفت أي
نوع من النشاط الإجرامي.
وأكد متحدث باسم كلينتون يوم الأربعاء أن
كلينتون لم تكن تعلم شيئًا عن جرائم إبستاين،
كما أشارت إلى الوقت الذي كانت فيه مع
إبستاين على إحدى طائراته و
قال الطيار إنه بحاجة إلى الهبوط في أتلانتيك سيتي،
قال جيفري إنه رائع، سنتصل بترامب وسنذهب
إلى لا أتذكر اسم
الكازينو ولكننا سنذهب إلى الكازينو كما
تقول في الإقرار الذي لم
تقدمه أبدًا  تدليك لترامب في عام 2002،
وصف ترامب إبستين بأنه رجل رائع، لكنه
قال لاحقًا إنه طرد إبستاين من
نادي لاجو الخاص به، ولم يُتهم ترامب بارتكاب
أي مخالفات عندما طلبت شبكة سي إن إن
بيانًا، ردت حملة ترامب
بمهاجمة وسائل الإعلام،
وتحتوي الوثائق أيضًا على بيان.  مقتطفات من إفادة مأخوذة
من المرأة التي تقف وراء الدعوى
فرجينيا روبرتس جي فري والتي
توصلت سابقًا إلى تسوية خارج المحكمة في
دعوى منفصلة تتعلق بالاعتداء الجنسي ضد
الأمير أندرو جيفرا زعمت في
شهادتها أنها كانت
جارية إبستين الجنسية وأن ماكسويل وجهها لممارسة
الاتصال الجنسي  مع أشخاص من بينهم
الأمير أندرو وحاكم نيو مكسيكو السابق
بيل ريتشاردسون الذي توفي
العام الماضي، لكن الأمير أندرو وريتشاردسون
نفيا ارتكاب أي مخالفات، ونفى متحدث
باسم ريتشاردسون أنه التقى على الإطلاق،
وأعتقد أنه من أجل الناجين وأنت
تعرف المحامين الذين  لقد
عملت بجد لتسليط الضوء على هذا الأمر
وأعتقد أنه يمنحهم شعورًا ببعض
الرضا وبعض
العدالة على الأقل لأننا نواصل
المحادثة، يقول محامي دو إن
الكشف يعزز
الهدف المهم المتمثل في إيقاف الاتجار بالجنس
أينما وجد ومحاسبة المزيد، فإن
الكشف عن هذه الوثائق
يجعلنا أقرب إلى هذا الهدف. قال محامو
جالين ماكسويل، التي كانت تقضي
حكمًا بالسجن لمدة 20 عامًا، في
بيان يوم الأربعاء إنها حافظت
باستمرار وبقوة على
براءتها